Xavier is with us in Los Angeles hey
Xavier how are you better than I deserve
what's up so I've been contemplating
getting adult braces I recently landed a
job that has great insurance government
type job and that pays for pretty much
half of what races would normally cause
I've been putting this on the back
burner because of how much they cost and
I'm still in debt currently between my
wife and I about 8,000 and credit cards
in his hand about five and a car payment
and I'm just I have some money that I
have set aside myself to either purchase
a car or get braces but I really want to
try to pull the trigger on braces but I
just can't seem to just do it what
Arnold income right now with this new
job and all the time I'm at about ninety
ninety five and my wife is a freelance
in the dance industry making about
thirty or so yes so you're making like
120 a year between the two of you and
how much are the braces twenty four
hundred bucks and half I had out half of
that as you know normally braces out of
pocket if I was just without insurance
would it be about five or six thousand
okay and 100 is out of your pocket yeah
okay so let's kind of count this up if I
did your debts right thirteen thousand
pays off your debts right and 2400 which
is fifteen thousand four hundred doesn't
it right if you had fifteen thousand
four hundred most of your problems will
be solved how much have you got the
savings since this new job I've been
able to save more often how much have
you gotten more consistent right now
it's about eight thousand okay so we
don't need fifteen thousand four hundred
we have eight thousand of it we only
need seven thousand bucks and you make
one hundred twenty thousand dollars a
year right
you're not looking at the whole picture
you're looking at tiny little pieces of
the picture you need look at the overall
thing I want you to get out of debt and
then I want you get your braces I don't
you to do both by Christmas if you don't
somebody that you're but if you can't
come up with seven thousand bucks out of
120 thousand by Christmas it's I guess
it's more like like should I pull the
trigger now since I will you should get
out of debt and then you should buy the
braces okay but I'm gonna use 7,000 of
your eight thousand towards your debts
so you told me you told me you had an
$8,000 car debt right yeah eight
thousand and credit cards yeah which is
unfortunately and uh like a debt
consolidation and how much how many
different credit cards for okay and and
then five thousand was on the car right
right okay all right so I'm going to
list your debts smallest to largest and
I'm gonna pay off the smallest seven
thousand dollars worth tonight and then
I'm gonna get on a written detail budget
and I'm gonna clear up the rest of that
a little bit of credit card debt and be
done with it forever chopping up all of
those cards very very quickly like a
month or something you're gonna be done
then you're gonna knock the car out okay
okay and then we're gonna save up for
braces and then we're gonna build our
emergency fund up properly to three to
six months of expenses see you haven't
been making this much money before now
this is a new job and you got the OT
opportunities and you got the
opportunity to really kick this thing
into overdrive right right yes so you
have the know you have this new
opportunity with this math to for the
first time ever to be on your side let's
start thinking about big numbers and
getting completely out of debt and big
building wealth more than just $2,400
braces I want you to I want you to do
the braces you're gonna do them I tell
you when you're gonna do you're gonna do
about October that's about where it's
gonna land okay and then you're gonna
build an emergency fund of three to six
months
of expenses the book that we have that
shows you how to do all this stuff in
order called the baby steps the book is
called the Total Money Makeover I'm
gonna send you a copy as my gift because
I want you to go win you're making
really good money don't wake up five
years from now and go house making a
hundred grand back then I got nothing to
show for it
that's what's gonna happen if you don't
get really intentional and really
focused and make every one of these
dollars be --have make them do what
they're supposed to do